welcome everyone to day 5 of digital
marketing week by simply learn on day 4
we looked at email and content marketing
today we are going to learn some of the
essential digital marketing tools that
every digital marketer needs to know
digital marketers rely on various
digital marketing tools to drive traffic
to the website convert that traffic and
retain customers digital marketing tools
and software allows you to create
inbound marketing strategies for your
marketing teams and optimize your
marketing campaigns for your potential
customers in this video we are going to
cover tools for seo paid marketing email
marketing web analytics affiliate
marketing social media and computer
analysis tools along with hands-on
demonstrations so let's get started with
learning the different digital marketing
tools greetings everyone this is rob
sanders with simply learn today we're
going to talk about digital marketing
tools so fasten your seatbelts and let's
get started so what we're going to do is
we're going to take a look at some of
the
best digital marketing tools ones that
have performed well in the past that are
popular and ones that we foresee as
being the go-to tools for the future so
past present and future digital
marketing tools is the way to look at
this uh with a good focus on a lot of
different marketing channels here so
we're going to focus first on seo talk
about some of the tools related to
on-page and off-page we're going to
switch over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that i use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so be good to kind of
see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are
you know best practices and
some of the most
popular or most used tools out there in
the industry so that's what we're going
to do the goal is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail and
what we're going to do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine about optimization or
organic search we have a mixture of paid
and free so there's a lot of different
platforms but if you're focusing on seo
you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's sem rush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyword planner and if
you know anything about seo you'll know
that using google's keyword planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another seo
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is google's
keyword planner and google's keyword
planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're going to
have high volume and low competition so
let's take a look at an example in
google's keyword planner so here i am
i'm in google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google has
given us here meal delivery so we're
going to just type in mail delivery and
get some results so notice i can enter a
domain as a filter and so in other words
hey i could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i can add another key to it if i
wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what google keyword planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here i
get a column for competition so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range 16.61
so that should alert me to the fact that
hey if i'm gonna try and optimize for
this keyword i know it's competitive
because not only google is telling me
it's competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is highly competitive so the
idea here using google's keyword planner
is one we want to get an idea of what
other keywords are out there that are
relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive then
it's probably going to take me a bit
longer to be found for this keyword on
page one of google so that's the whole
idea behind google's keyword planner and
note that you could change some of the
settings here so if you want to choose a
different language okay you can hone in
on a longer or shorter period of time
you can even choose a specific location
so i chose taxes i can certainly choose
the entire united states to get a sense
of what the volume would be for the
total us so you have settings that you
can change and manipulate to get you the
data you need to choose keywords so
that's the whole idea behind google's
keyword planner to find relevant
keywords high volume low competition now
alternatively i can certainly use
another tool
to find keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask moz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from
eleven and a half thousand to thirty
thousand on monthly volume now what moz
does is they give you a difficulty score
so a difficulty score is a score between
one and one hundred and so i could see
this is pretty much right down the
middle in terms of difficulty okay so if
it's zero it's an easy keyword if it's
if it's a hundred it's very difficult
and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so
here i could see
keyword delivery plans delivery services
etc so i can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to moz
related to seo for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use google's keyword
planner because maybe you're not running
google ads you can always use mazda
remember moz has
basically a freemium version meaning you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you can test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use moz we want to be able to
use google's keyword planner not only to
search for all those relevant keywords
available to you but we want to be able
to choose keywords with high volume and
low difficulty low competition we also
want to select primary and second
keywords wisely so remember when you
optimize you're optimizing a page for
more than one keyword so you want to be
able to have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so moz gives you that
information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this
we got a nice webinar on keyword
research for seo so take a look at that
video on youtube and to get more
specific details about using seo tools
for keyword research and all about
keyword research in general for seo so
let's talk about some other reasons
under seo what we would use some of
these tools available to us well we want
to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic
hrefs again moz let's take a look at
google search console and i want to hone
in on google search console because it
is free and it's a must if you're going
to work on seo you need to be working in
google search console and so the whole
key behind google search console is you
have a website and you need to get that
site verified once it's verified when
school
can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so here i'm looking at a
website and what am i looking at i'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these pages back to their server
they're letting us know
if we actually have any issues so here i
could see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a
4-4 you know redirect okay so you could
see there's some five unique issues
across 112 pages so here i could see
submitted url marked no index there's a
hundred of those pages we have some
redirect errors there's seven pages that
you'll fall victim to this error and so
we can really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google then we should
probably address the error and so that's
the great thing here about going into
google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
okay so these are the errors i could see
they
certainly were able to crawl and index
9115
pages they were able to crawl okay and
they excluded 54 000 plus pages and then
we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of
what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they discovered via the sitemap
and so
the whole point of a sitemap is we want
to be able to get and push the urls to
google not have google come to our site
and discover them so this is a quicker
faster more efficient way to communicate
with google all the urls that you have
on your site that you want google to
index and so that's the beauty of search
console now while we're in search
console we might as well take a look at
some of the other features it has and so
one of the most important features under
search console is this mobile usability
report okay so google is a staunch
believer in mobile first so nowadays
most people start and finish
a lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and
they may end it on mobile so if they
don't end it on mobile then you know
perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today
starts with mobile so they want you to
understand
how your site fares
via mobile and when i say fares via
mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to google
standards and so if there are any issues
google is going to let you know what
those issues are so here i can see
google's recognized 206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here i can see for
206 pages text too small to read click
elements too close together the viewport
not set to device width and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if i
actually click on it the error i can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
google telling google look i see what
the issues are i'm going to fix them and
then i want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
google's attention google's going to
validate them and get these pages
indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or may be of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search console shows us
what pages have the most links okay so
here we can see the home page has 26 000
plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i can see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so
externally i want links from other
websites pointing to various pages on my
site and i certainly want my pages
linking to one another on my site and so
i'd be able to better understand what
that structure looks like using google
search consoles links report okay
there's one more report that i think's
of interest in google search console and
that's the performance report so the
performance report is a report that
actually you can link up with google
analytics so you can see the same report
and analytics if you're able to link up
google search console with analytics and
you should be able to do that all you
need to do is make sure you use the same
email address that you use for analytics
and search console so it needs to be the
same email address you could certainly
link up the two and have this data
imported into google analytics so what
is this data that we're talking about
well it's called performance so what we
can actually see is the queries the
actual queries people are typing in to
google so when they're typing them into
google we can actually see
how many impressions the keyword queries
received and how many clicks the keyword
queries received and then i can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here i can see for this
particular keyword on the first line i
could see
over the course of the last three months
it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used at le
or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the
209 000 297
into the 120 000 397. okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you a click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57
so
over half of the clicks occur
when this listing appears for this
keyword okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so we could see a
little bit more than that too we can go
from queries to pages we can go from
pages to countries so we get a sense of
how many impressions and clicks i'm
receiving by country and importantly we
can see by device so here i can see a
majority of the people who conduct a
search related to my website primarily
do it on desktop now i mentioned the
beauty of the google search console
performance report is that you can link
it up to google analytics and when you
do that all you need to do then is go to
acquisition google search console and
then from there you could choose landing
pages countries devices or queries so i
can see the same data that i see in
search console but this time i'm looking
at it in google analytics and so here i
can see what my search queries are my
clicks my impressions my click-to-rate
bike search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
site maps to keyword research but we
also want to hone in on you know what
domains are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
google search console report but if you
have a platform like moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we could
certainly see where they rank the great
thing about moz is it's a great tool not
only for rankings and on-page
optimization but
for off-page optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain i'm going to be able
to get what they call a domain authority
so a score out of 1 in 100 i'm able to
see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if i click on the linking domains i'm
going to be actually able to see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazd even takes it a step
further they also give me a spam score
so moz is able to measure how spammy a
website is so if i have a combination of
say a low domain authority
and a high spam score then i probably
want to disavow myself from that site
and so i can use this report here you
can see here as i keep going down for
example i can see this particular
website has a domain authority of 26 and
it has a spam score of 16
so not a good combination this should
alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that i
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is i'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then i can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority
spam etc everything you need to use in
order to measure off page seo so that's
the great thing about moz is they have
not only on-page seo tools but off-page
seo tools and moz is a freemium so to
speak so here you can see if you just go
to moz.com
free dash seo tools you'll be able to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for seo but also for local seo
as well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so i use and lean on moz a lot for
all that it has to offer from
choosing keywords to rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos and
check them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools google's keyword
planner
moz and google search console okay let's
switch over to email marketing tools and
so with email marketing tools we have a
lot available to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know mailchimp to me is a tool i use i
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at mailchimp but there are certainly
many others available you know marcato
is a good tool you know marcato is a
good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to
you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma you know
feel free to to note that in the
comments section below this video i'm
curious as to how many people actually
use you know different tools because
there are so literally so many email
marketing tools out there why because
email marketing has been around probably
the longest amongst all the other
digital marketing channels and a lot of
people use email on a daily basis so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you could certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email b etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that
you know has various email templates
available okay you don't want to be
stuck with just a vanilla template again
you want to be able to customize an
email for your audience you want to be
able to manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of of recipients clicked on your email
what links do they click on you know
which which emails bounce so you want
some detailed insights right in the
platform that you're using it just makes
it more simpler and easier and more
effective to manage you certainly want
to create those smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time and day so these tools also allow
you to
you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multi-variant
testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use mailchimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp
once you log in you know you're going to
be able to see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on august 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is and then we can
certainly design the email so if we
click design email again this is
important because with email marketing
you want to be able to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own so you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but i
really like the reports that they have
to offer
so you know here you can see there's
some lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so
here i could see this email that was
sent out in june i could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers
okay of the subscribers i saw 2 000 plus
open it and 157 clicks so i can view
this report in more detail just by
clicking on view report so again we want
an email platform that's going to be
able to give us some detailed
information about how that email
campaign performed and so i can get down
really to the nitty gritty i can
actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here
so if i click view report i can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here i'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16
percent i only had an open rate of 2.5
percent so the industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you could link it with a
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products and
somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the cart
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
mailchimp and summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some similar features but that's
what you ideally want to look for in an
email marketing platform so here's a
tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because most people
in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have up to five parameters that i can
use okay so here's my email or url that
i'm using in the email so i have up to
five parameters that i can use to track
this particular email so let's go
through some of those parameters
so the first one is campaign source so
what's the source of the campaign well
we could certainly identify
mail champion for using mailchimp as the
source now the the thing about the url
builders you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive so as a rule of thumb
just stick with a lowercase so our
source is going to be mailchimp because
that's the platform we're using if
you're using you know constant contact
or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email i would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do i say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say
you have 10 000 recipients i want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's gonna get
subject line one
and one segment that's gonna get subject
line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one is
in the campaign content field so now i
have four parameters
and once i've entered in my variables in
those parameter fields i now have a
revised or pended url so my original url
was visit florida.com slash ian-us
florida-beaches.html my original url
i've now appended that with some utm
parameters
and now i see my original url
appended with the utm parameters based
on those variables so i can copy it just
by clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there and i want to check to see
if it works so here i could see this
particular page loaded florida beaches
with
my utm parameters appended to the url so
that's for the first subject line that's
for the audience that's going to get the
first subject line i want to do another
one for the second subject line so now
i'm going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
i'm going to copy that url i'm going to
check it
okay so i could see that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i going to do i'm going to use
the first url
and the second url in my email okay so
any link that i have in this case i'm
using subject line two so for the email
with the second subject line going to
that segmented audience this is the link
i'm going to use in the email so if you
have one or two or three links in the
email this is the url you're going to
use because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in google analytics so if i
jump over to google analytics after i
send out my email i'm going to go to
acquisition i'm going to go to campaigns
i'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables i put into
my parameters meaning source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what i'm going to look for in google
analytics so we can start with source
and medium
so if i click on source and medium as my
primary dimension
here i can see
mailchimp and the actual dates was used
as part of the variable for for source
and then i will can i see the medium
being email so now i can see for this
email that was sent out in mailchimp in
may i could see
how many users how many sessions and
more importantly how many conversions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here i could see the
campaign name okay so i could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see the subject lines in this
case
if i go back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the url
builder again you're taking a url that
you're going to use in email and then
you're going to pan that url with
different parameters campaign source
campaign medium campaign name
and then optionally campaign content or
campaign term okay once you've entered
variables into those parameters you're
going to get an appended url which you
can then use in your email so when the
email gets sent you're going to go back
over to google analytics and you're
going to look at the results of that
campaign of that source of that medium
of that content i.e subject line and so
that's why
the url builder is so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates but what we
really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools
and this is an important section because
web analytics tools kind of the central
focal point of all digital marketing and
it starts really with google analytics
google analytics is a freemium meaning
that they have a free version that you
can use there is also a paid version of
google analytics but given the advent of
google its popularity especially in the
united states a majority of users are
using the free version of google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just google so we have adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
youtube analytics which is part of
google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well again we want to really
measure behavior we want to measure
what's going on with our website so we
want to be able to identify the location
of where our website visitors are coming
from and a lot of these analytics tools
use ipaddress to identify the location
of a website visitor so if you're trying
to target a specific country then you
want to be able to see that the visitors
to your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is at treating
our website visitors with the same
courtesy you would if you had a brick
and mortar store somebody comes into
your store you want them to find what
they're looking for quickly you want
them to be happy with their experience
you certainly want them to pay for the
products very quickly and easily and
efficiently and you want them to come
back and that's no different than a
website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you want to be able to measure organic
traffic whether you like it or not
whether you know it or not but google
and other search engines are indexing
your pages and your pages are being
found via the search engines and so you
want to be able to measure how much
traffic you're actually generating from
those search engines we talked about
this with email marketing utm tracking
so if you set up email campaigns or non
google campaigns you want to use utm
tracking and google analytics and other
analytics tools but specifically google
analytics will help you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do i.e are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion in that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
rob sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
san francisco california came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device
and they're a returning user so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but
they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i go
to demographics overview here's a
picture i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that 63 of my
traffic and again this is year to date
that i'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so
i'm painting a picture about you know
gender and age coming to my website well
i can also look at geo so where
specifically might these people be
coming from so if i go to location under
geo i'm going to be able to see a
breakdown of country or i can even hone
it down to city
or specific location and here i can see
the united states is the primary driver
but not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the us
and then 16 from argentina 13
from mexico 10 from india so we have a
nice mix
of traffic from different locations in
the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case i can see
year to date i can see 62 percent are
coming from desktop 35 percent are
coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey from mobile and that is
growing and that's going to continue to
grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic when this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email
social then i could see more paid search
broken out so these are the different
marketing channels now analytics allows
you to look at a specific source and
medium so the source would be the actual
website or search engine and the medium
would differentiate how that traffic
actually got to the site so if we're
talking about a search engine did they
come to the site via paid search or do
they come to the site via organic search
and so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and medium and we can
see specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here i can see
google organic at 71
and then google
cpc or cost per click at 15 16
of our traffic so then i can look down i
could see email in here being organic i
could see some referring sites i could
see some social in terms of mobile
facebook okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources and mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via source and medium and if
you're running google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in google ads so if you're
running campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also
see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google campaign with utm
tracking so when we do that we'll be
able to go to campaigns
all campaigns and we'll be able to see
the campaign performance if we look at
source and medium we'll be able to see
what campaigns drove traffic to the
website so here i can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search
consoles so we looked at search console
earlier we talked about seo tools well
remember i said you can link up search
console with google analytics well
here's search console and we could see
queries devices landing pages countries
so all the performance metrics that we
could see in search console because we
have it linked up with analytics we can
see it right here so this gives us a
nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the clicked array and then
the average position so in theory the
higher something ranks the more traffic
you're going to get so that's the idea
behind it we want to make sure that
we're ranking for our coveted keywords
and if we are we want to be able to
measure how many times our listing was
seen and how many times it was clicked
so that's the great thing about you know
google they have a family of products
and those products tend to talk to one
another in the form of google search
console and google ads you can connect
them directly to google analytics so
let's move from acquisition to behavior
so
here in behavior we have a number of
different reports so behavior tells us
once the traffic actually arrived at the
website how are they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with the page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique pages which is
equal to sessions
so i can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session i could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and i can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so i can
also see percentage of exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from so these are all engagement
related metrics so here is where i want
to react and optimize my website
performance so i if i see a page not
performing well meaning it has a high
bounce rate or maybe low time on page
then i'm probably going to optimize it
meaning test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i could see this
particular page on line one had
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so if a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so when we load up the
speed suggestions report what google
does is say hey we know that this page
is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually gonna
happen is you're gonna go to another
tool called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see if i
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that i can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here i could see there's some server
response time issues image sizes
probably need to be resized i can remove
unused css okay so there are a lot of
different things i can do to improve the
page load time on this particular page
okay this is for desktop i can also see
mobile so mobile a lot of the same
issues so if we address these these
opportunities then we could see a lift
and page load time we see lift and page
load time we're going to probably see a
lift in organic rankings or even user
engagement because if a page takes a
long time to load a user is probably not
going to stay on that page very long so
to me
site speed is an important report under
behavior now one more report here that i
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here we could see for our particular
website we have categories already set
up for event tracking so here for
example i can see on line six video i
could see how many people actually
watched our video okay so here's the
action video start okay so over this
period of time i could see
i had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watched
the video and you can always report to
label and that'll tell you what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure engagement so
if you go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so
what you want to do is you want to be
able to set up your events through
google tag manager which is another
google platform but you certainly want
to do that so that's where you set up
your events when you set up your events
for your website with a category an
action and label you'll be able to
measure those events in analytics under
behavior under events and the important
thing here is you'll be able to measure
engagement so i'll be able to see how
many people came to the site and how
many people clicked on a button
downloaded a pdf uh submitted a form
played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events are important so let's move from
behavior to conversions and this is
important because we want to be able to
measure conversions on a website so
analytics has four types of conversions
so if i go to admin down at the bottom
and then i go to goals i could see that
i have four different types of goals
that i can use now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if i
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it i can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here i could see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure
our goal completions over this period of
time so here i could see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
goal type so remember the only goals i
have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter sign ups
156 donate click buttons i have
32 contact form submissions 37 email
click completions and then 11 phone
number click completions so i can
measure engagement as a goal and so
goals generally are important to the
business so you want to make sure that
if you have a goal for your website then
you want to be able to set that up as a
goal in google analytics so that way
when you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if i want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the donate now button
i could see that i could see
year-to-date ten thousand eight hundred
eighty-seven users which meant eleven
thousand sessions 76 clicked on that
donate now button and that's comes out
to 0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign
mobile device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see
in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data in order to improve website
performance now let's jump over to
youtube analytics because if you have
videos on youtube if you have a channel
set up some playlists you'll be able to
get some really good insights as to how
your video is performing and so here i
could see
i'm in youtube all i did was i went to
my account then i went to the beta the
studio version of youtube and then from
there i went to analytics so my account
youtube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
i could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
and
i've netted 48 subscribers and this is
an overall okay so i can actually see
when i publish videos and i can see the
date they were published and here i'm
looking at you know total views over
this particular date range i can also
see specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly look at some
other information if i click on reach
viewers i can see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so
here i could see the different traffic
sources so 29 came externally okay here
i could see 25 came within youtube
itself i could see how many times a
video was viewed and played via playlist
via suggested video so i could see
different ways in which the traffic
found my video and actually watched it
here i could see externally how people
were able to find my videos and i could
see 46 percent found it via google
search see some lots of information here
about sources of traffic how the traffic
got to these videos so i could see then
once the traffic found my videos how
many times they actually saw it and
viewed it and then watched it so that's
how many times i was able to reach
viewers via different sources and then
their reaction to that how many times i
saw it and watched it here i can click
on interest viewers so again i could see
the top videos in terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partner's
playlist was the top playlist so i can
see some interest here in terms of
average view duration and then here we
have build an audience so we can look at
specific audiences if we have them built
in youtube to see how many people
actually watch my videos so here i can
see 88 percent of the people who watched
my videos over the last 28 days were not
even subscribed so that tells me a lot
of people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself i could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via youtube search i could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it i could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to hone in
on how your videos are performing so if
you have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition is
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool socialblade
there's a popular tool out there called
spyfu that's freemium as well
moz we looked at moz earlier for keyword
and organic moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
freemium tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn i use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in their ranking so the reason
why we have this is the top bullet point
is because seo organic search is a
long-term strategy on-page off-page
website very technical and creative
there's a lot going on with seo a lot
going on and sometimes it takes a long
time to rank for something and a lot of
seo does depend on relevancy relevancy
being how many quality backlinks are
linked to you so it's always good to
leverage what your competitors are doing
so you can see how you stack up and so
that's why this is up there as number
one we want to be able to really take a
look at what our competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much
traffic a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competition is doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our
competitors data and compare it with our
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with sprout social
and sprout social is a tool i use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do
with sprout social definitely generate
reports for your social media platforms
you could set up post that get published
at a certain time and day but there's
also one particular tool in here called
listening and so what we could do is we
just put in for example rv rentals in
twitter so what we're doing is we're
actually listening to see who else is
tweeting about rv rentals so we could do
this for twitter we could do it facebook
some other social media platforms the
whole idea here on sprout social is to
get a sense of what our competitors are
doing so we could have easily put in a
brand name we're just going general here
because we want to rank for the keyword
rv rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go rv
rentals cruise america rv we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword rv rentals now if i
want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand names
or every share so here i can take a look
at you know what they're doing when
they're posting to or tweeting how long
ago the time of day get an idea of what
they're actually saying what campaigns
they're promoting okay i can get a sense
of everything about this tweet and so
here i can scroll down and i can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and i can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so
to me it just gives me a sense in this
particular example on twitter as to what
our competitors doing okay let's turn
our attention to seo so remember that
first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so moz
has a great tool called link explorer
and link explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain i can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of
you know how many links my competitors
have external intel internal i can get a
sense of the domain authority i can get
a sense of page authority linking
domains so i can really do a
comparison across my domain and my
competitors domains to get a snapshot of
how i compare against my competitors so
this gives me an overview of everything
i need to know organically now moz also
has a another great tool under link
explorer called link intersect and i
like link intersect i use it a lot
because if our competitors
really have a number of external links
and domains pointing to their site and
they have a better domain authority and
page authority then you know i want to
be able to you know see what they're
doing where they're linking who's
linking to them i want to get be able to
get a snapshot of why is their domain so
much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so i can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then i can find
opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you can see
where
my site intersects
with their site and if it doesn't
actually intersect then i have an
opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then i have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the link
intersect tool is in moz it allows me to
really get a sense of you know where i'm
linking and where my competitors are
linking now what we can also do is also
take advantage of another report under
moz's link explorer and the discovered
and lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so
really within mods we can get a good
snapshot of what websites are linking to
our competitors we get a good snapshot
of the overall links to our competitor
sites and specifically with sites so the
whole idea is if it's good for our
competitors meaning they're linking from
a site that has good domain authority
and low spam score then it's probably a
site i want to be able to tackle as well
okay so you have discovered and lost
okay you have comparing link profiles
and you have link intersect so those are
three good reports you can leverage
right in moz's link explorer tool now
there's one more report we can leverage
in moz and that's the inbound links
report and so we can go ahead and type
in our competitors domain here and again
we can get a snapshot of what their
domain authority is page authority for
the home page but really this is what
we're after linking domains so this
particular domain has over 9 000 linking
domains so what we can do is actually go
through and see based on domain
authority i could sort by domain
authority where these pages are being
linked from and so here i can see reddit
reddit reddit so a lot of reddit here
which is a good site for backlinking new
york times so you know there's a lot of
different uh
sites here washington post so i can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course i don't want to go
through 9 000 links i can really just
hone in on a specific link source or
link type or link state so i can really
filter it if i wanted to i can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as i
could see what url
is linking to this particular competitor
site with the anchor text is what the
page and domain authority is so this
gives me a really really good insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if i'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on reddit
then we probably need to be on reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from reddit which has a domain authority
of 90 then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so
inbound links is it just another good
report you can leverage in moz under the
link explorer reporting tool now if i
want to get a good snapshot as to what
my competitor's doing on search exactly
well look no further than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a ppc seo perspective you know from
an seo perspective you got some back
linking data as well just like you did
in moz from a ppc perspective you can
get some good keyword insights and so
here i just went ahead and typed in the
domain and what this is going to do is
just give me an overall snapshot for my
competitors domain so here i could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
seo clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords
okay i can see here the keywords their
top competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years so this particular
domain has been around a long time okay
so that's on the organic side you can
flip over to the paid side and i could
see that they are doing paid search i
could see 5 000 plus keywords they're
bidding on okay based on that what
they're actually paying and then i could
see you know some of the other
competitors listed here from a paid
perspective and an organic perspective i
could see the shared keyword overlap
okay now again you can pay for this
because it's freemium and get some
really good insights as to how your
domain compares to your competitors so
i'm using the free version and here the
free version spyfu is just giving me
some overall data on the specific domain
i entered in and so i entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is google ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase
okay here you can see some even some at
google ads history i could see exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword and then i
can see some organic ranking history
here as i keep scrolling down this
overview report so i can see for rv rent
where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfus providing me with some insight as
to hey what links are pointing to them
and what the domain strength is and how
many clicks they expect to receive so
this is all free data take it or leave
it but it's all free data available to
you under spyfu so spy view gives you
kind of an overview for free some really
in-depth analysis if you actually pay
for it and it just really hones in on
what your competitors are bidding for
paid wise and what they're ranking for
organic-wise and so spyfu is a really
good tool to leverage if you just want
to get a snapshot of how your competitor
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to google analytics because in
google analytics under audience i can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all anonymous data so i can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if i hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and i hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that i get then i could see hey
analytics in this case in this example
sharing
863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and i can compare those web
properties against my own so for all in
the same industry it gives me a sense
here as to how i stack up against the
industry as a whole in this case as it
pertains to channels so you can see here
red not good green is good so in the
industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and
we can adjust our locale and if we do
that google is going to be able to
adjust how many web properties are
actually contributing to the report and
so when analytics makes that adjustment
we're going to be able to see in this
case just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand and
we're going to go with 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so we're
focused on the new zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report after i've honed in
i'm looking at channels and i can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare against the
competition i can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels i can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site size meaning how many sessions you
actually get on a daily basis and then
analytics will do the rest they'll
compare you against those in your
industry and so i find this to be a good
tool because it allows me to stack up
our site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say from
organic then we have our work cut out
for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmark report now if you
want to get some good insight as to what
the competitors are doing and you don't
want to use a tool well look no further
you can always go to google.com okay so
this is how we used to do it back in the
day before all these tools became
available you just typed in a keyword
and we're going to type in rv rentals
and now we're going to be able to see
who's bidding on that keyword so we
could see we have a number of different
uh companies bidding on the keyword
we're interested in okay here i can see
some featured snippets okay and then i
can see some organic search results okay
if i scroll down i'll be able to see
some other companies bidding on that
same keyword meaning they're paying for
rv rental so if i clicked on somebody's
link here they're actually going to pay
google for the click and so this just
gives me a good sense of you know how
many people are actually trying to rank
for this keyword or trying to be found
for this keyword so that's all i did i
just did a search now from an organic
perspective if you really want to hone
in on your competition you can always do
the syntax all in title colon and then
hit enter so now i could see i have 163
000 results and what does that tell me
that tells me that i have 163 000
websites with rv rentals in the title
tag so if you're trying to optimize for
the keyword rv rentals as an example
then you know that you have 163 000
different listings ahead of you that you
need to jump over in order to rank for
the keyword rv rentals so using the all
in title syntax and the keyword right
after that actually just gives you a
more accurate picture of how many sites
are actually ahead of you for a
particular keyword so that's the whole
idea so if i get rid of the syntax and
you can see for rv rentals i have 132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword rv rentals in the title tag and
title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind using the all in
title syntax it gives us a good idea as
to what our competition is doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running google ads just as we did with
rv rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for rv
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns google ads actually has a good
report that i really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is
what competitors or domains are bidding
on the same keywords we are and so what
google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for
all the keywords we're bidding on and so
here i'm looking at year to date and
here we could see us and i can see our
competitors okay so i could see
impression share so for if we're talking
about one keyword every keyword has a
100 impression share how much of that
impression share are you getting and
when we say impression share meaning
eyeballs when we talk about eyeballs are
we getting a majority of the eyeballs or
our competitors get a majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position i can see how often i overlap
with my competitors okay i could see how
often i'm above a particular competitor
i could see what percentage i'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then i
can see how often i outrank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so i could see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords i am okay so this is if you're
running google ads okay so if you're
running google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find that the top navigation just by
clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on google bing linkedin you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so
you know if you're doing paid search on
say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage
okay and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes
you have google ads keyword planner of
course both of these are paid if you're
running campaigns okay so bing if you're
running campaigns on bing okay you get
all this good data that you can digest
through some reporting okay you also
have some third-party tools out there
that you also have to pay for in word
stream okay so
word streams a third party tool that you
can leverage bing and google
are actual advertising networks so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as i mentioned you could also
use google ads editor
so bing also has their own editor as
well so and as well as facebook so you
can use an editor type version and i'll
show you that here in a couple minutes
but let's talk about why we want to use
the tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting now they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information in the case of auction
insights as to how
your competitors are performing against
you on google search so that's on the
paid search side then you have display
okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example adroll okay you know
curtillo celtra is another paid version
of or paid tool you can use in wide
orbit so these are some of the paid
marketing tools you can leverage
of course i like to stay if i'm
advertising on google i like to stay on
google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage adroll's reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and ad performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and right customer engagement
so when it comes to display we want to
be able to make sure we're choosing the
right audience of course that means
looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple minutes okay so we want
to improve our campaigns by monitoring
our competitors display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that and that's on the display
side if we look at social
okay why what tools can we use on social
well you got facebook ads manager okay
you got ad espresso choir tweepy you got
all these cool paid search tools again i
usually stick with where i'm advertising
so if i'm advertising on linkedin or
twitter i'm going to leverage that
platform but just know that there are
other tools available for you so with
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights in this
example about facebook users how are our
users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then
with facebook as an example we can
monitor any a b test we run for example
if we're running call to action test we
can measure the results that write in
facebook and i'm going to show you an
example of that here shortly so let's
jump right into google ads and look at
some tools available to us
from the search side of the house so if
we're running search campaigns right in
google ads we could see campaign data we
could see keyword data we could see
ad data so for example if i want to see
what ads are performing i'm just going
to click on my ads and extensions okay
and here are my ads and now i can see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in the
google ads platform itself now if i want
to look at specific keywords i can do
that so i could see what keywords are
driving traffic and clicks here i could
just sort by clicks and now i can see
not only what keywords are driving
clicks i could see
what the click-through rate is i could
see the impressions how many people
actually viewed my ad after click typing
in a keyword query that i'm bidding on i
could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality scores
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so
this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about the keyword reporting is
that there's some other features
available to me here so here i can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords
i can also see a search terms report and
so when it comes to search terms i can
actually see
what specific keywords people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query i can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if i see a keyword query that i don't
particularly care to be shown for or
want my ad shown for then i can go ahead
and just select it and i can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in google ads
okay and then you have the auction
insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords and what the impression
share is what their average position is
what the overlap rate is position above
right top of page absolute top of page
right now ranking chair so once we have
google has data then they'll be able to
share that information with you okay so
that's just keywords but there's a cool
tool that i really like and i leverage
it for seo and pay-per-click and that's
google's keyword planner so if you click
on tools and then you click on keyword
planner we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much i
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
i happen to click on that keyword i can
add it to a plan and then once i've
added to a plan then i can go ahead and
look at that plan and
measure what kind of volume i'm going to
get and how much i can expect to pay so
now once i've added my keyword to that
plan i can go ahead and see how many
clicks and impressions and costs and
click the rate and average cost per
click i can expect to spend so
and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see
basically how much i can expect to spend
so that's the whole idea behind the
keyword planner in terms of choosing new
keywords and once you choose keywords
you're interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend how
many clicks how many impressions you can
expect to get and
if you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so
there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mention this as one
of our key defining why would we use it
bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about
google ads is right in google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example
do a bid adjustment on computer and that
means i'm going to show my ads less so
i can go ahead and do bid adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and
if i see a particular location i'm not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it and i can always just
pause it or remove it so
or i can change the bid adjustment on a
location as well so i can make a lot of
different changes right in the google
ads platform for those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them to google ads to the account
on google ads in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor it's a great tool for you to
use if you want to make household
changes really quick for example i'm
looking at an account with a bunch of
campaigns so now if i click on one of
those campaigns i could see the ad
groups here okay so for example i just
wanted to turn off all these ad groups i
can just highlight them all and just
click status enabled to paused and i can
revert back if i want to okay so you can
make household changes so here i could
see the campaign the ad group level if i
choose an ad group then i can see some
keywords and again i can make changes at
nauseum here i can copy i can paste i
can delete okay so i can make a lot of
changes really quick right in google ads
editor and that's the whole point of
editor is to go ahead and work locally
while somebody else is working locally
on the same account you could both be
working
simultaneously and being more efficient
on getting things done in the campaign
now if you are working with somebody
else on the campaign you want to make
sure that you get recent changes so if i
say get recent changes to all campaigns
what google editor is going to do is
contact google ads in the cloud and
download all those changes so here i can
see the changes being download in editor
from google ads and when it's done it's
going to highlight all the changes that
have been made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
write an editor in fact you could do
pretty much most of what you could do in
google ads you can do in google ads
editor and so that's google ads editor
to me i would recommend it if you're
experienced with google ads again it's
software you have to download it you're
going to use it on your computer as
software but when you make changes all
you need to do is post those changes or
get recent changes that have been made
on google ads and so that's google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform's
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
network as well as for the display
network right in google ads so if i want
to take a look at a campaign an ad group
on the display network i can just click
on that ad group and i can look at the
ads that are running for that particular
ad group on the display network so here
the difference being on the display
network is you can use image ads on the
search network you can only use text ads
so here i can look at image ads and i
can see
how they're performing in fact you could
even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc
right on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i could
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side i could see clicks
impressions click to rate more
importantly i want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword ad
whatever the dimension is so here on the
display network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see demographic data and so now i could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that google provides us and i
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and i could see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site i can go ahead
and see exactly where that placement was
so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising i
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on google ads okay
so take a look at the google ads
tutorial we have set up on youtube okay
if you search for google ads tutorial
2019 this is a good uh tutorial on
everything related to google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on google ads as most people
do then you could see just how powerful
it is and all the different features
that are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complementary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and
this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any
tools or features on google ads whether
it's the search network or whether
that's the display network then feel
free to comment below this video happy
to hear your comments about what tools
and reports and features you
specifically use in google ads so let's
move into uh facebook ads manager and
show you how the platform looks when
you're running ads on facebook so we can
look at all the different tools and
reports available here so here we can
see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we can see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads how many people
are actually looking at the app and i
can see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so
now i can go in and i can go ahead and
look at the ad performance and go ahead
and change out that ad if it's not
performing to
my expectation so if i click on more
tools and then creatives i can just
simply click on creators and then i can
actually see the creators i actually
have running for that campaign i
selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has uh reap
different reporting so if i click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
i could see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender and then i can see
all reports here listed out by placement
by placement and device time of day
country etc so if we just look at age
and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so
you can see by campaign i'm looking at
all campaigns here and i'm looking at
just age and gender i can certainly
deselect one of these
and i can look at a specific time range
so now i can see who's looking at my ad
specifically so here i could see
35 to 44 female i could see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad
a lot they're probably going to tune out
to it so that's what makes the frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and
you know turn off that particular age
and gender if we needed to and we could
see how much we spent so this just gives
you some idea of the type of reporting
that's available
in facebook ads manager now the great
thing about facebook
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup
my dimensions if i needed to
i could change the view and arrange
columns i can get rid of columns just as
you would in google ads reporting very
similar stature here so i have a lot of
flexibility here on how i review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you could pick and choose
as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here i can
pick and choose i can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again i can choose
different demographics so i have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how i want to
you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my ad
set or my ad now remember
if you're in facebook you can always go
in and edit the campaign you can edit
the ad set remember in the ad set that's
where a lot of your decisions are going
to be made including how you want to
drive the traffic okay what your budget
is okay you can basically choose your
audience here so you're going to be able
to choose what type of campaign is going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit it out remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you right in ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
facebook so if you want some more
information about
all the different features and tools and
facebook ads manager check out the
facebook ads tutorial 2019
a webinar that we did earlier this year
in addition you can also look at another
one that we did on facebook called
facebook advertising tips and strategies
so that should give you some sense of
everything related to facebook ads and
how to take advantage of the facebook
ads manager platform so if there's
anything on social that we may have
missed or that you use feel free to add
a comment below the video we'd love to
hear your feedback okay let's talk about
some affiliate marketing tools let's
turn our attention affiliate marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they have
a freemium model meaning you can have a
free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are brokers per
se and when i say brokers like for
example with cj you as a merchant or you
as a publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning cj helps
bridge the gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so
that's what really affiliate marketing
is and you really need a platform to
kind of put it all together and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify
you know affiliates inflowers employees
other advocates you want to partner with
so again you'd be on the merchant side
you could be actually selling a product
and you're going to want somebody to
help you sell that product somebody with
a website who's an influencer who drives
a lot of traffic to their own site who
you know does sell reputable brand etc
so
you need somebody to help you introduce
you to these sites okay so cj and some
of these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do i mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am i only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're going to want to be able
to set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you could set up
with terms and conditions for say 10 off
all sales as an example okay well you're
gonna need a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social
so you have a lot of
benefits to working with affiliate
marketing in itself and the tools
available will help you gain website
rankings as one example we want to be
able to track
certain metrics okay so an affiliate
marketing you have earnings per click
epc as an example most platforms measure
epc from a seven day period to a three
month period okay you can also figure
out what the actual cost per click is
just like you do on say google search
you can actually measure that in
affiliate okay you want to eliminate
fraudulent clicks impressions and
conversions so any affiliate platform
worth its weight is going to help you
understand you know how many impressions
and clicks and conversions you're
getting and help you manage that in
terms of fraudulent clicks or hey if
you're getting a lot of impressions and
no clicks that's a problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on hey did somebody go to the
website did somebody see our product
does somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell a product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so
we go into cj.com we're going to log in
and here you can see a publisher's link
so we're going to click on the
publishers link and remember when you
sign up publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program terms we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program so remember
you could set up your own program term
for any publisher
so as a best practice if you have
publishers who are actually performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here
we can't or these publishers can't make
any money if they don't generate clicks
so that's why you have an epc model or
metric so to speak so you can measure
earnings per click cj does it over seven
day period and over a three month period
so you could sort based on seven day or
three month to see who's earning the
most per click in terms of publishers
now you can select under publishers
groups now you can group your publishers
okay so if you have say a group of
publishers in a specific region like the
united states or india or if you're just
focused on the united states and say you
have publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm gonna repeat it is
you want to get
publishers and you want to start
building your base of publishers because
the more publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so if you have publishers who
are promoting your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're gonna finish up
all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay
the first one i can think about here is
hootsuite hootsuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here
you you basically a base account and
then uh you can use hootsuite to do a
lot of things anything from setting up
landing pages to actually publishing
content to listening hootsuite to me is
one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available you got buffer
buffers a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got
tweetdecks been around a long time that
is actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're gonna take a look at
that here in a couple minutes okay and
then you got sprout social sprout social
is another social marketing platform
similar to hootsuite do a lot of
reporting a lot of publishing you can a
lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at sprout chelsea today as
well before we do that
let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you can manage
everything one place then these social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one twitter account
but multiple twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor
the results so monitor social media
posts that help drive leads and sales in
other words you're going to have a lot
of different metrics associated with
each social media marketing platform
okay which one is actually doing its job
okay so you want to be able to easily
manage these platforms applications and
websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log into each
platform is log into one place get a
sense of what's been posted what the
engagement is did they purchase etc and
what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on real-time data so
if for example you post something using
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are
running
ads on facebook or you're posting on
facebook as an example or any platform
in general that platform's going to have
its own
metrics if you will so for example
facebook has something called facebook
insight so you'll be able to actually
see you know what's been posted based on
you know the last seven days in this
example how many page views you're
getting engagements recent posts so just
to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads okay you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log into twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so i don't have
to log into facebook directly i can see
you know the impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time i can
see my audience growth i can see my
publishing behavior how often my
publishing i can see the top post
individually i can see impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is already in facebook
insights so if it's available on
facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know i can go to instagram you
know and look at instagram data or i can
look at twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other
using in this example sprout social now
as i mentioned as part of one of the
benefits of a social media tool is that
you can publish content you want to be
able to publish content because you want
to be able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile
write whatever we need to do you can
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so you want
to be able to schedule accordingly
because again when you schedule
something then you want to look at the
behavior of it so it's just as simple as
going from publishing to reporting and
then based on when something got
published you could see the reaction of
it and react to it so another thing here
that i like about it's about social
hootsuite a lot of these other platforms
do it really well you got listening
tools so you can listen in on
conversations that are being had for
example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location a radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout social's
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar spot social in
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing i like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so i could see
today i have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again i
have five profiles set up for this
account so i can pick and choose the
profile that i want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com
is that you know you have a library of
images that potentially you can reuse so
if i click on this image here okay i can
get a sense of when it was used and i
can view it on a calendar i can add
label for it so that's another benefit
to later is that they have this media
library here they have conversations so
i can actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being had similar to the listening tool
in sprout social and they have analytics
so you can actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
could see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i can see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received okay so i want to be able
to see how my particular platform is
performing over a period of time so i
can look at reach a lot profile views
website clicks okay so i can get a lot
of good insights here right in the
analytics platform later you can look at
specific post performance so we posted
something i could see basically how many
likes it received how many comments
impressions the reach and then if i
wanted to i can click on details and get
more specific information on it
engagement rate okay discovery actions
comments saves etc so later.com goes
into some nice detail about post
performance they even have date on
hashtags so if you use an hashtag you
can actually see how many times the
hashtag's been used or saved how many
impressions it's received okay so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweak deck so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
can see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different
things that are trending on twitter so
you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
could see the you got the cricket world
cup you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that
friday feeling in their tweets and so
the whole idea behind you know tweet
deck it serves up a interesting overview
so to speak of not only your account but
you know a specific topic or what's
trending or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social
later.com you know facebook insights so
it does cover in more detail some of
what we covered on these social media
marketing tools so take a look at how to
start social media marketing so we
covered a lot of different marketing
tools digital marketing tools everything
from seo to email to social to paid to
affiliate to competitor but there's also
a few other digital marketing tools that
you can use in different ways like video
seo for example so vid iq you know we
want to use vid iq to get a good sense
of how a particular video is performing
so here if we go into youtube you can
see vid iq is a browser extension or
browser a plug-in if you will
so i can go and take a look at a
specific a specific video and see how
many hours it's been watched how many
views minutes watch subscribers etc you
know the great thing here i can look at
the entire entire account so
i can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid iq extension into my chrome
browser so vid iq actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid iq because it's good
for video seo okay there's also tools
related to
content optimization so
you know if you're doing seo and you
have a lot of content on your site well
you know what we want to be able to use
a tool
maybe a third party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo then they may
pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for content optimization you know
there's also other key reddit but you
know there's keyword planner uh in
google there's also a word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a google
ads platform and so if you don't have
google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to google's keyword planner
so having a third party keyword tool
will pay dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click but also seo and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in social
then you may want to take a look at the
keyword tool keyword it and it's
primarily used for reddit we talk about
page load time so we looked at that in
google analytics we know that it heavily
impacts seo so there are other tools
available you got a third-party tool
here that's free solarwinds pingdom you
actually have page speed insights by
google so these are free tools that you
could take advantage of and determining
how you can improve your page load time
my favorite topic conversion rate
optimization so you got a couple in here
crazy egg and target okay so i'm going
to show you another tool called hotjar
so here if you log into hotjar.com you
can set up an account it's actually free
and with the free account you can have
hotjar measure the heat map not only the
heat map but the click mapping the
scrolling of a particular page and so
here you can see we're looking at a
particular page here so hotjar allows me
to
you know see on that page where people
are clicking um i can also see where
people are moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so
you can see here on the page i can see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
i switch over to move mode then i can
see on that particular page where people
are actually moving their mouse and then
i have my scroll analysis so i could see
you know how far down people actually
scroll on the page and so again with a
paid account you can measure up to ten
thousand page views with the free
version you can measure up to two
thousand pages and so two thousand page
use allows you to get some insight as to
what people are clicking on or where
they're moving or how they're scrolling
on a particular page and so i definitely
recommend hot jar they also do funneling
they also do forms polls lots of other
tools available in hotjar so hotjar.com
is a tool i would recommend as well so
one final tool and i'd be remiss if i
didn't mention it and that's google
optimize so google optimize is a google
platform that allows you to a b test and
so a b testing means that you have an
original page and you're changing one
element on that page to see which one
performs better and so with google
optimize it's just very easily to set up
to run and the whole point of google
optimize and a b testing is to improve
website performance so here you can see
i have an account set up and optimized
you can see we're running one test here
and we're just testing one element
versus the original so we move photos to
the top of the page the original didn't
have the photos to the top of the page
and so we can go into reporting here
google optimize does all the heavy
lifting and so here you could see
we can look at bounces or we can look at
you know basically a measure the test up
against the metric that's important to
our business and again the whole point
is to improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests and that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
google optimize is a tool that i would
recommend okay so we could probably go
on for a few more hours on all the
different various types of digital
marketing tools that are out there on
the internet we covered a lot of them
from paid to email to social a lot of
them are free a lot of them are paid
versions in between you got freemium so
go out there experiment have fun play
around if you have a tool we didn't
cover that you feel our audience should
know about then go ahead and put them in
the comments section under this video
now we have reached the end of day 5 of
our digital marketing week on day 6 we
are going to learn about paid marketing
thank you all for watching today's live
session see you all tomorrow until then
keep learning
you